partir surfer en iran quelle idée bon
c'est pas la mienne c'est celle d'un ami
qui voyagent qui servent beaucoup et qui
savait que personne encore ne se refait
en iran mais il savait aussi qu'il y
avait potentiellement des vagues dans le
sud est du pays dans une région qui
s'appelle belgistan que la région qui
est en rouge sur la carte de sécurité
diplomatique
c'est plus mettre une tête de mort il
l'aurait fait je pense alors le
baloutchistan qui est plus connu
éventuellement pour son trafic d'opium
que ce ses plages magnifiques aux portes
du désert probablement pour ça que
personne encore n'avait surfer et
pourtant donc cet ami m'a mis en contact
avec une surfeuse hernandez il a
organisé le voyage on devait partir tous
les trois et il a raté son avion ça
arrive du coup je me suis retrouvé tout
seul avec cette serveuse que je ne
connaissais pas on s'est rencontré pour
la première fois à terrain on a vite
sympathisé et on a décidé de continuer l
aventure et c'est comme ça que
l'histoire est devenu 100 % féminine on
est parti quelques appréhensions
pourtant les locaux étaient très
contents de voir du surf pour la
première fois sur la plage j'ai fait un
petit film de ce premier voyage qui a
fait le buzz sur internet et derrière on
a eu des retours d'iraniens et d'iranian
qui voulait savoir son pensé revenir du
coup en 2013 on a décidé de repartir
cette fois ci avec plus de planches et
moi j'ai voulu allier mes deux passions
pour le cinéma et pour le sport et faire
cette fois ci un long métrage de cette
nouvelle odyssée
alors quand j'ai organisé le projet j'ai
imaginé qu en fédérant un groupe de
femmes autour du surf ce serait plus
facile de
d'encourager d'autres femmes à se jeter
à l'eau du coup j'ai fait des recherches
et j'ai trouvé deux sportifs iranienne
déjà très engagé dans leur discipline
menacé rajhi qui est professeur de
snowboard à téhéran et shalaya cynique
qui a les nageuses à zahedan
je leur ai écrit pour savoir s'il
voulait venir et apprendre à surfer
elles m'ont dit oui sans hésiter et vous
avez vu mon petit film donc à ces
demandes et justement si on allait
revenir donc c'est comme ça que le surf
est arrivé en iran on était quatre
femmes et on a on peut le dire introduit
le surf dans la république islamique
d'iran
alors faire un film c'est compliqué
faire un film en iran ça demande un peu
plus de logistique quand je suis allé
voir les boîtes de production elles ont
toutes trouvé l'idée fort sympathique
mais pas forcément faisable vu la
difficulté de tournage en iran dont je
n'ai pas trouvé production pas de
production pas de financement mais moi
j'y croyais vraiment très fort à cette
histoire donc par la force des choses
c'est clair j'ai autofinancée et
autoproduit ce film et grâce à mes
proches qui ont toujours été là et aussi
aux donateurs des plateformes
crowfunding j'ai pu financer ce
documentaire qui me tenait tant à coeur
ça c'était le premier obstacle ensuite
ils se sont enchaînés l'obtention du
visa
les autorisations de finhan l'iran
l'envoi des planches dans un pays sous
sanction mon caméraman qu'on empêche de
partir à la dernière minute et puis au
départ une seule semaine de visas pour
faire un film d'une heure donc jusqu'au
dernier moment j'ai cru que je n'y
arriverai pas j'ai eu un visa de
justesse 1 mardi soir en septembre 2013
grâce à l'ambassade qui m'a beaucoup
soutenu je suis partie le mercredi matin
une des raisons qui me pressait c'est
qu'à partir du mois d'octobre il n'y a
plus de vagues pendant une longue
période
alors c'est un vrai concept pour les
gens qui donnent des visas mais c'est
quand même une réalité pour faire un
film de surf pas de vagues bathurst
ensuite il ya la sécurité je me sentais
évidemment très responsables ou des gens
qui m accompagne pendant ce périple et
c'est seulement en arrivant sur place
que j'ai compris qu'il ne nous
arriverait rien parce qu'on a été invité
à rencontrer le membre du parlement
iranien de la région monsieur jobs
galles et certains des hommes les plus
influents de la région
il nous a invités pour savoir qui en
étaient et éventuellement ce qu'on
venait faire alors trois heures de thé
plus tard un bon repas beaucoup de temps
tomine et on est repartis rassurés parce
qu'ils nous ont garanti qu'ils allaient
assurer notre sécurité
et monsieur jo de galles mais aussi
promis qu'il ferait en sorte que je
puisse fumer sans problème c'est à dire
que personne ne m'empêche de le faire
on a continué la route
je me suis tu as de galles j'ai oublié
on a continué la route et on a trouvé
une petite vague et devant un village de
pêcheurs qui s'appellera mines et c'est
là qu'on a décidé de se jeter à l'eau
pour la première fois un c'est un moment
émouvant parce qu'on ne savait pas
comment les gens allaient réagir en
voyant des iraniennes dans l'eau et je
vous laisse imaginer que quatre femmes
qui de loin dans l'impression de marcher
sur l'eau et qu'ils sont bien déterminés
à ne jamais baisser les bras ça ne passe
pas inaperçu du coup on a vite été
entourée des hommes des garçons parmi
eux il y avait un jeune va lucho qui
s'appelle chams qui est vite devenu un
rôle modèle pour les enfants est aussi
très vite devenu un meilleur ami alors
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'au début il
voulait savoir si eux aussi avaient
droit à l'enfer parce que comme on était
que des femmes ils ont cru que c'est un
sport de femmes
et comme on est très cool on a dit ok du
coup on a surfé ensemble les hommes d'un
côté les femmes de l'autre sauf que
la vague a nous a tous réunis mais mucha
c'est toute la magie et la beauté de ce
sport c'est qu'une fois dans l'océan ont
subi et ça fait du bien de s'oublier la
culture le genre la religion l'océan il
s'en fout
donc sans le vouloir on a brisé une
règle est naturellement la pratique du
surf et de vie mixte alors on a surfé
ensemble pendant une semaine on a eu des
maris qui nous ont demandé de faire ça
refait leurs femmes des papas qui nous
ont demandé de faire surf et leur fille
et c'est à ce moment là simplement que
j'ai compris pourquoi j'avais fait tout
ça pour quoi j'avais rien lâcher
pourquoi j'avais pris mon premier cheveu
blanc voulant faire un film de surf en
iran c'était pour vivre ce moment là ces
moments de partage
dans un océan qui ne fait pas de
différence
tout ça c'est en images mon film est
terminé il est distribué il a déjà été
diffusée dans plusieurs festivals
internationaux dont téhéran et san diego
en californie
alors c'est très symbolique mais pour
moi c'est important d'imaginer qu'il ait
suffisamment objectif pour être diffusée
partout et si l'objectif c'est parce que
je les réaliser avec une équipe de
grands cinéastes iraniens eu de la
chance
ensemble on à confronter nos points de
vue pour parler d'un pays dont je
n'avais ni les codes ou les complexités
et grâce à eux j'espère j'ai pu donner
une autre image de l'iran qui est
finalement un pays que l'on connaît mal
quand on dit une histoire comme ceux ci
on a envie que ça dure
du coup avec mes amis rien on a créé une
association qui s'appelle le surfing
vannes et l'année dernière on a organisé
des cours et il ya eu des iraniens qui
sont venus des quatre coins du pays pour
essayer le surf des gens de teyran de
shiraz mashatile fans c'était magique
surtout que si j'ai bien compris c'est
rare de voir d'autres iraniens d'autres
régions côte à côte avec des valeurs et
une fois de plus ça s'est passé dans
l'eau
habib le frère de chams qui était membre
du jury alors non on a organisé une
petite compétition
qui consiste à s'exprimer dans l'eau et
à faire ce que tu veux et surtout ce que
tu peux à ce niveau là pour t'amuser et
pour surfer et habib le frère de chaîne
ce qui était membre du jury a
particulièrement insisté pour que le
récompense marc gène qui est une femme
baloutche parce qu'ils pensent qu'elle
servira de rôle modèle pour les femmes
baloutche donc c'est lui qui a tenu à ce
qu'on lui donne un prix pour sa
persévérance et pour sa détermination
et une fois de plus avec cette histoire
j'ai vu à quel point c'est important
pour les femmes de pouvoir faire du
sport pas seulement les iraniennes pour
toutes les femmes et le plus important
c'est de pouvoir le faire
la dernière fois que je suis partie au
baloutchistan
c'était au mois de mars
alors je vais pas vous mentir avec
l'actualité quotidienne dramatiques que
l'on reçoit du moyen-orient il m'arrive
parfois d'imaginer que c'est peut-être
dangereux de partir tout seul au
baloutchistan mais ça ne dure pas parce
que je m'interdis d'avoir peur je
m'interdis surtout de donner raison à
tous ces hommes qui dépensent leur temps
leur argent et leur énergie à faire de
ce monde un champ de bataille et
si j'arrête de partir au baloutchistan
et d'aller voir mes amis à cause de la
peur j'aurais l'impression de relancer
et ça ça n'arrivera pas alors quand j'ai
un doute je whatsapp chams qui me dit
mais roubaix roubaix et rob skis en
iranien est dans ma traduction veut dire
et cocottes détends toi ça va bien se
passer
du coup vous à me rassurer je prends un
billet
donc j'ai passé quinze jours avec chasse
dans sa famille tous les deux on ne
parle pas la même langue pourtant on se
raconte plein d'histoires voire même on
se la raconte alors beaucoup ligne
des dessins un peu de farcir un peu
d'anglais une grosse dose d'autodérision
et on parle on parle de nos projets on
en a plein construit une école de surf
sur la plage de ramine donner la
possibilité aux enfants de fabriquer
leur propre planche avoir une fédération
de surf iranienne
donner la possibilité au plus grand
nombre de pouvoir pratiquer le surf et
puis moi un projet qui me tient à coeur
c'est de nous permettre à nous les
femmes de surfer dans de bonnes
conditions
parce que je n'en ai pas parlé mais oui
ça fait un voile c'est compliqué pour
l'instant les tenues sont pas adaptés
donc c'est même presque dangereux du
coup ça énerve donc avec une styliste
franco iranienne on est en train de
développer une collection de vêtements
aquatique qui sera dédiée à toutes les
femmes pas seulement musulmane mais dans
ce cas là en iran qui permettra de
donner accès au plus grand nombre de
pouvoir pratiquer des sports aquatiques
avec des vêtements confortables pratique
sécurisée et féminin
cham ce film parle de son projet d'avoir
un petit restaurant ou vendre l etrat
des plats traditionnels baloutche et
aussi un jour de venir surfer en france
je lui souhaite même si c'est très
compliqué pause iranien d'avoir des
visas pour la france
alors shamsi les baloutche musulmans
sunnites il a grandi dans un petit
village iraniens à la frontière
pakistanaise son père à quatre femmes il
a 15 frères et soeurs je suis française
ate et laïque j'ai grandi dans un petit
village bressan à la frontière suisse a
priori mon père n'a qu'une femme j'ai un
frère tous l'aider on est très
différents
pourtant on est amis c'est clair on ne
parle pas la même langue mais on est
devenus confident et surtout on a une
croyance commune on croit tous les deux
très très fort en cette belle histoire
sportive que l'on était en train
d'écrire en iran celle d'un sport qui
fait tomber toutes les barrières celle
du surf
moi j'étais pas à l'école du coup on m'a
orienté vers les sciences la voie royale
je suis diplômée en mesures physiques
pourtant j'ai vite compris que c'était
pas fait pour moi alors j'ai pris ma
caméra et mon sac à dos et je suis parti
sur la route j'ai fait un choix un choix
qui n'a pas toujours été facile à
assumer parce que la société le système
sont parfois cruels avec les gens qui
décident de sortir du cadre
j'ai été serveuse par mail femme de
ménage je serai dans les usines
responsable de magasin caissière
cuisinière j'ai habité quatre en
nouvelle zélande je travaille dans des
fermes j'ai appris à tondre des moutons
et ramasser des kiwis j'ai conduit des
camions je donnais des cours de français
découvrent le snowboard j'ai fait des
crêpes des french connect sur marché
j'ai été caméraman
webmaster projectionniste j'ai travaillé
pour le lonely planet je n'ai jamais été
meneuse de revue du lido
actionnaires bûcheron je ne sais pas
maintenant je suis réalisatrice c'est ma
passion je crois même que c'est plus
beau métier du monde j'ai toujours
imaginé que la vie s'était comme à long
métrage est que chacun avait les moyens
d'être l'auteur de son propre scénario
merci